le talentueux monsieur ripley roman de
patricia highsmith a fourni son point de
départ au film plein soleil
ce film en effet s'en est inspiré le
talentueux monsieur ripley c'est à la
fois un roman psychologique est un roman
policier mais surtout un roman
psychologique puisque toutes les actions
et vu à travers le principal personnage
rené clément est ce que dans votre film
vous avez respecté ses dimensions
oui ces dimensions là je les ai
respectées
mais si on parle de dimensions je dirais
qu'il est évident que l'on ne pouvait
pas traduire directement le livre de
madame patricia smith qui est de
redonner un film d'une longueur
démesurée
nous avons simplifié et ramener comment
dirais-je aux mobiles les plus les plus
directs du personnage est ce que vous
pourriez justement nous définir ses
mobiles qui sont toute la trame de
l'histoire est bien paul gégauff et moir
ont travaillé à l'adaptation pour cela
en faisant en sorte que tom ripley et
qui est joué par alain delon représente
ce que nous avons dans la jeunesse
d'aujourd'hui
ces espèces de grande impatience de
posséder et son camarade qui mord israël
n'est est riche
à grandir est une présentation sociale
qui l'envient il n'a envie ils
convoitent ce qu'il a de telle façon que
il voudrait prendre sa place
être lui en mieux et cela nous amène à
une véritable histoire d'amour avec
marie laforêt puisque dans ses calculs
dans ses plans car c'est vraiment
l'année chez lui et il va oublier cette
dimension qui est l'amour
il va tomber amoureux sans le savoir de
cette jeune fille qu'il faudra posséder
bien entendu pour être vraiment le
maurice ronet qu'il enviait et il
voulait donc plein soleil c'est un titre
qui est pris à la fois au sens propre et
au sens figuré
les deux en effet plein soleil à cause
de tous les extérieurs que nous allons
tourner un film d'extérieur nous avons
tourné en italie ensuite de l'italie
j'essayais de neige dans cet excès de
lumière d'ivresse de lumière qui se
confond avec le sens figuré qui était
d'essayer de prendre cette place au
soleil qui nous rappelle le titre de
notre film ou d'ailleurs le personnage
n'est pas tellement éloigné de celui ci
rené clément si vous le voulez bien nous
allons maintenant laissé plein soleil de
côté il ne reste plus aux
téléspectateurs qu'ils allaient voir le
film vous avez simplement donné les
jalons les points de départ en ce qui
vous concerne il ya tout de même une
chose remarquable c'est que vous tournez
très rarement des films vous tourner un
film tous les ans ou même un film tous
les deux ans est ce que vous pourriez
nous dire si cette rigueur absolue est
spécifique à rené clément c'est à dire
si vous estimez que vous avec votre
nature avec votre personnalité vous ne
pouvez pas vous exprimer
si vous tourner un film en trois mois à
quatre mois cinq moi aussi moi aussi au
contraire c'est une règle que vous
considérez valable pour tous les autres
cinéastes
je la considère valable pour tous elle
peut être elle est applicable pour tous
ceux qui travaillent comme moi c'est à
dire vous êtes un auteur complet bon
c'est à dire ceux qui font leurs films
maintenant ceux qui se contentent de
faire uniquement la mise en scène est
évident qu'ils peuvent tourner autant de
films que le temps de tournage leur
permet si ils ont été trois mois pour
faire un film se retrouve à 4 12 il fera
quatre films il n'y a pas de juste
milieu entre les deux entre le metteur
en scène des bisons et kadio manière de
travailler
il me reste plus qu'à prendre
rendez-vous pour dans un an par
conséquent
oui forcément c'était attendu